a three-day travel ban is in force in
portugal's capital lisbon
authorities are worried about the
growing number of cases of the
coronavirus delta variant
slowing down traffic in an attempt to
slow down the spread
of covert 19. police began checking
drivers entering or leaving lisbon on
friday afternoon
authorities announced the measures just
the day before but officers say most
residents knew
something was coming their way
despite the short notice drivers know
the rules
they're aware of the ban on leaving or
entering the lisbon metropolitan area
and we've seen much less traffic than
the usual friday afternoon
lisbon's 2.8 million residents can only
leave the area with a valid reason
and those living outside are barred from
entering
they're tough measures but most people
appear to accept them
i think it's really difficult to have an
opinion but i'm relatively confident
about what the government decided
i think things are being decided in the
face of the uncertainty of the situation
most people here are very aware of just
how dangerous the virus can be
portugal was hit hard earlier in the
year the country's health system was on
the verge of collapse
after a lockdown was imposed in january
the tide gradually turned
infection rates dropped and restrictions
were almost completely lifted
but less than a month after portugal
reopened its borders to tourists from
the uk
and the rest of the eu the country is
seeing a new surge
the government blamed the rapid spread
of the delta variant
for the sudden increase in cases
we're still waiting for more data more
official sequencing data
but the indicators are pointing towards
a greater dominance of this variant
this is why it's important to take this
decision
portugal's government says it's
monitoring the rising cases
and whether the snap travel ban will be
repeated
will be decided weekly
you